good evening so good to be here so this
past weekend my teenage daughter yells
at me from across the house mom put down
the microphone
step away you're scaring us and I would
love to tell all of you that I was
practicing for this evenings event but
no instead I was alone in our living
room playing Glee for we anybody else
play this fantastic in-home karaoke game
any brave souls willing to raise their
hands all right a few a few and I'm not
sure why I'm obsessed with karaoke
because I suck like I'm really really
bad like really bad I've had friends
family members perfect strangers
actually inform me how much I suck but I
love it
jesse is it okay I'll stop go to song
Jessie's girl but yes I'm absolutely
obsessed with karaoke and so the crazy
part is that my favorite way to do
karaoke is with work colleagues now I
know a lot of you are thinking what are
you nuts
making an ass out of myself in front of
people that I have to work with day in
day out and
nfw not going to happen but the reason I
love it is for those Joe from accounting
moments you we all know Joe Joe is that
quiet shy guy that sits in the corner of
the office headphones on mesmerized by
spreadsheets doesn't interact with
anybody else leads lunch at his desk so
we're all surprised when Joe accepts the
invite for karaoke and not only does Joe
show up Joe puts a
grabs the mic and from the top of his
lung belts out sweet child of mine by
Guns and Roses our jaws are on the floor
who is this man
any perceptions that we had about Joe
are completely obliterated but the best
part is when you return to work that
next day all of a sudden the headphones
are off Joe's actually talking to people
interactions in Sioux collaboration
begins because we saw Joe for Joe and if
you think about karaoke it is probably
one of our most vulnerable moments right
especially for us sucky singers and this
word vulnerability has gotten such a bad
rap over the last couple years as being
weak being taken advantage of but
vulnerability is what creates
connections karaoke vulnerability
connections and especially now with
social media where there is so much
posturing everything is perfect look at
all my family and friends and the
beautiful vacations that I take when we
know it's not and I share this story
because when I look back at my 20 25
year career vulnerability was absolutely
a key characteristic in my own success
when I started as an entry-level Account
Manager back in 1999 I'm sure many of
you were still I don't know where I
don't want to know I'd be free I knew
nothing about internet marketing I knew
nothing about affiliate marketing and be
free proceeded to give me the largest
account at the time now who's crazy
you're giving me the largest revenue
generator I know nothing about this
space and I had my wits about me I don't
know how or why to take a step back and
figure out what did I know
and whether it was my journalistic
instinct or I had a successful sales
stint prior to I knew I could make
connections so that's what I did for
those first three to six months is I
tried to get to know everybody in
anybody that could help me admit in
terms of what I did know and what I
didn't know because I knew that mistakes
would be made I knew that I would
absolutely eff up but if I had strong
connections with the client and with my
colleagues I knew that we could work
together through any of those challenges
and that we did we survived the dot-com
boom the dot-com bust and not only did I
never get kicked off the Barnes and
noble.com account remember these guys
still trying to compete with Amazon but
I got more accounts and I eventually got
more people in which to help me manage
those accounts and that really began my
own leadership and stepping-stone on a
go-forward basis a couple years later at
be free though I definitely hit somewhat
of a low point I was working for one of
these management by fear bosses anybody
else ever worked for one of these yeah
lots of fun huh definitely lots of
yelling heaven forbid you challenge him
or her in a group setting I dreaded
weekly staff meetings didn't feel
inspired at all and felt instead felt
very demoralized but it was also that
same time that bfree was actually
getting ready to integrate with our
closest competitor at the time which was
Commission Junction and we actually had
a lot of combined leadership meetings
talking about people and process and
technology and it was in one of these
meetings and I was still working for
that boss that it was the bfree
leadership team on one side of the table
and the Commission Junction one on the
other side talking about a variety of
different concepts and I kind of sat
back was fairly quiet because again
didn't have much conviction or
confidence at
point in time and after the meeting one
of the female executives pulled me aside
her name was Lisa and she said I've
talked to you before I know that you
know more about some of these concepts
than anybody else in this room why
didn't you say anything you need to
speak up we need your voice in order for
this integration to be successful we
need a diversity of thought we need
different perspectives and I will tell
you this one conversation gave me back
that confidence gave me back that
conviction and I started challenging
that fear by management boss because I
knew that Lisa was in my corner I knew
that she had my back and I know we've
all heard the stats we make up women
half the workforce but only 25% of us
actually possess an executive level
position only 6% of the sp500 actually
has female CEO so as you get higher we
become fewer we must use our voices we
must support one another yes we can
protest for equality but it's even the
smallest of things that nod to another
in a meeting the shaking of the head the
congratulatory comment after someone
gets done with a presentation it's those
little things that make the difference
do not compete but collaborate so
because of this vulnerability and these
connections I not only had amazing women
throughout the course of my career but I
also had a few good men and I wish it
was Jack Nicholson and Tom Cruise but
that's besides the point I did have a
few good men actually emerge and I know
there hasn't been many as of late when
we think about the Weinsteins of the
world and the bill o'reilly who have
done disgusting and deplorable things
but we cannot stereotype them all
in 2007 the president position opened up
for Commission Junction and the position
was based on the West Coast I was
currently living in Boston and I was VP
of the East Coast
and as I said the position opened up and
it was myself and one of my peers that
was also very much interested in the
position
he was male he was much closer to the
position on the west coast
he had more experience than I did he had
more revenue responsibilities than I did
and we both demonstrated very similar
results and our CEO was responsible for
making the decision and his name was Jim
and many would categorize Jim as an old
white guy because he was 60 plus years
old at the time he was white and while
he was a guy but at the end of the day
Jim chose me because he didn't see
gender he didn't see male versus female
instead what he saw was the role and the
requirements for success and yes
somebody that could demonstrate results
but also had that Drive had that ability
to make connections and when I talked to
Jim after the fact I said why he said
your willingness to learn admitting what
you do and do not know that growth
potential that vulnerability and I was
president from 2007 through 2015 where I
grew that company double-digit
year-over-year growth 14 offices 400
employees it was a great great run so
I'll leave you with this we need more
leases we need more gems and we all need
more karaoke in their lives
thank you very much
[Applause]